it's late at night and some type of
nocturnal predatory bird maybe this is
an owl is diving for its dinner so this
right over here is
this right over here is a mouse and it's
diving straight down near a street light
let's get some information about what's
going on so the street light right over
here is 20
is 20 feet high
so this is 20
a 20-foot high
street lamp
and right at this moment the and i
haven't drawn it completely to scale the
owl is 15 feet above the mouse
so this this distance right over here is
15 feet
and the mouse itself is 10 feet from the
base of the lamp
let me draw that so the mouse
is 10 feet
10 feet from the base of the lamp and we
also know we have our little radar gun
out we know that this owl is diving
straight down is driving straight down
and right now it is going 20 feet per
second so right now this is going down
down
at 20
feet
per second
now what we're curious about is we have
the light over here light is coming from
the street lamp in every direction
and it creates a shadow of the owl so
right now the shadow is out here and as
the owl goes further and further down
the shadow is going to move the shadow
is going to move to the left like that
and so given everything that we've set
up right over here the question is
at what rate is the shadow moving
so let's think about what we know and
what we don't know and to do that let's
set up some variables
so let me draw the same thing a little
bit more geometrically so let's say that
this is
this right over here is the street light
that is 20 feet tall
and then this right over here
is
the height
of
the owl right at this moment so this is
15 feet
the distance between the base of the
lamp and where the owl is going where
that mouse is right now this is 10 feet
and if i were to think about where the
shadow is well the lights emitting from
right over here the light's emitting
right over here and so the owl blocks
the light right over there so the shadow
is going to be right over there so if
you just draw a straight line from the
source of light through the owl and you
just keep going and you hit the ground
you're going to figure out where the
shadow is so the shadow
the shadow is going to be
the shadow is going to be
right
over here it's going to be right over
there and we need to figure out how
quickly is that is that moving and it's
going to be moving in the leftward
in the leftward direction so let's set
up some variables over here
so let's say so what's changing well we
know that the height of the owl is
changing so let's call that y
right at this moment it's equal to 15
but it is actually changing and let's
call the distance let's call the
distance between the
between the the shadow and the mouse
let's call that distance let's call that
distance
x
now given this setup can we come up with
a relationship between x and y and then
using that relationship what we're
really trying to come up with is what is
the rate at which x is changing with
respect to time we know what y is right
at this moment we know what d y
d t is right at this moment can we come
up with a relationship between x and y
and maybe take the derivative with
respect to t so we can figure out what d
x d t is at a given
moment in time
well both of these triangles and when i
say both of these triangles let me clear
let me be clear what i'm talking about
this triangle right over here this
smaller triangle in green
is a similar triangle to the larger
triangle it's a similar triangle to this
larger triangle that i am tracing in
blue it's similar to this larger one how
do i know that well they both have a
right angle right over here they both
share this angle so all three if they
have two angles in common then all three
angles all three angles all three angles
must be in common so they are similar
triangles which means the ratio between
corresponding sides must be the same so
we know that the ratio of x to y
the ratio of x to y must be the ratio of
this entire base which is x plus 10
to the height of the larger triangle 2
20. and right there we have a
relationship between x and y and if we
take the derivative of both sides with
respect to t we're probably doing pretty
well
now before taking the derivative with
respect to t i could do it right over
here just to simplify things a little
bit let me just cross multiply so let me
multiply both sides of this equation by
20
and y just so that i don't have as many
things in the denominator so on the left
hand side it simplifies to 20x i don't
want to write over well i'll just write
20x and on the left hand side or sorry
on the left-hand side it is 20x and then
on the right-hand side let's see this
cancels with that we have xy
xy
plus
plus 10
xy plus 10y and now let me take the
derivative of both sides with respect to
time
so the derivative of 20 times something
with respect to time is going to be the
derivative of 20 something with respect
to the something which is just 20.
that's the derivative of 20x with
respect to x times dx the derivative of
x with respect to t
is equal to
now over here we're going to have to
break out a little bit of the product
rule
so first we want to figure out the
derivative of x with respect to time
so the derivative of x with respect to
time so the derivative of the first
thing times the second thing times y
plus just the first thing times the
derivative of the second thing so
derivative of y with respect to d is
just d y d t d y
d t
and then finally
right over here the derivative of 10 y
with respect to t is the derivative of
10 y with respect to y which is just 10
times the derivative of y with respect
to t which is d y
d y d t and there you have it you have
your relationship between
between d x d t d y d t and x and y
so let's just make sure we we have
everything this is what we're trying to
solve for dx dt and let's see we have
another dx dt here we're going to try to
solve for that
we know what y is y is equal to 15. we
know what d y d t is d y d t if we make
the convention since y is decreasing we
can say it's negative 20. so we know
what we know what this is and so if we
just know what so we know what this is
so if we just know what x is we can
solve for dx dt
so what is x right at this moment
well we can use this first equation we
could actually use this one up here but
this one is simplified a little bit to
actually solve for x so let's do that
and then we'll substitute back into this
thing where we've taken the derivative
so we get 20
times x
is equal to x times y
x times y y is 15
and just remember i could have used this
equation but this is just one step
further we've already cross multiplied
so it's x times y y is 15 so it's x
times 15 plus 10 times y
plus 10 times 15 plus 10 times 15. did i
do that right 20x is equal to x times 15
plus 10 times 15 10 times 15.
so let's see if you subtract so just
this is 20x is equal to 15x
plus 150 subtract 15x from both sides
you get 5x is equal to 30. divide by
sorry 5x is equal to 150. my brain is
getting ahead 5x is equal to 150 divide
both sides by 5 you get x
is equal to 30 feet
x is equal to 30 feet right at this
moment so this distance just going back
to our original diagram
this distance right over here is 30 feet
so let's substitute all the values we
know back into this equation to actually
solve for dx dt
so we have so let me do it right over
here we have 20
20 times dx dt i'll do that in orange
we'll solve for that actually i already
used orange so let's say dx dtl uses
pink 20 times dx dt is equal to dx dt
times y
y right now is 15 feet so times
15
times
i didn't want to do that color
times
times 15
plus x we already know that x is 30 plus
30
times d y dt what is d y dt d y
d t we could say is negative 20 feet per
second y is decreasing the bird is the
bird is diving down to get its dinner so
times
negative and that's just a well times 20
feet per second so that's that right
over there
plus 10 times dydt
so plus 10 times negative 20 feet per
second and now we just solve for dx dt
so let's see what do we have we have 20
times let's see let me subtract 15 dx dt
from both sides of this equation and we
get 5 dx dts
5 dx dts i just subtracted this from
both sides of the equation this is 15 dx
dts this is 20. so we have 5 dx dts is
equal to
this is this part right over here
is negative 600 and this part right over
here is negative 200 so it's equal to
negative
800 feet per sec or negative 800 and
actually this will actually be in feet
per second and so dx dt
is equal to dividing both sides by 5 5
times
16 is 80. so this is negative 160
feet per second and we're done and we
see the shadow is moving very very very
very fast to the left x is decreasing
because we see that that's why we have
this negative sign here the value of x
is decreasing it is moving to the left
at quite quite a quite a nice speed here